I'm going to ask this is a good question
is a baby worth your career
would you say
no no
so you wouldn't ever give up your career
for a child
no I would do both
okay I would like to think that if I
have obviously I don't have kids at the
moment but if I had kids in the future I
would I would still keep my career
because I want to progress
yeah so um how many hours a week do you
work
60 plus 60 plus 65 hours a week yeah
probably so who who would watch the kids
I would have to pay for child care okay
so you'd want to pay someone else to
raise your kids
um I don't think they would all
obviously
uh yeah I don't I think they would
always be raising them they would
technically I mean 65 hours a week they
would yeah if you had a choice because
hopefully hopefully your man's working
as well so maybe I would cut down my
hours but I won't give my career up for
the child no way I'd I'd still like to
progress in doing that I'd like to think
that I could provide for that child as
well would you be okay with the the man
not working
no if I'm working he's got work too my
funny status
because we both need to provide if I'm
working however many hours a week 40 or
I can't have a house husband and look
after the kids yeah
[Laughter]
what if he earns enough money to look
after you the kids would you start yeah
but what if he leaves or if he left what
if he stays he can take off he could do
but it's 50 50 isn't it so no I'm I mean
that you ever have you did you go to
college
um did you graduate no okay 70 to 80
chance so there's only a like 20 to 30
chance he leaves
so it's like most likely that you would
leave not him
mom's still gonna still gonna progress
in my career even if there was more
chance of me leaving than him I wouldn't
expect him to give up work as I wouldn't
either because if I expected him to give
up work and there's more chance of me
leaving what is he gonna do do you think
that's selfish
to not give up work yeah like then like
what about the kids you neglect the
children I mean yeah you should have
kids yeah and it's more likely that
um someone outside of the home could
abuse a child
like a lot of kids get to be I mean
there's horror stories that people DM me
of like getting abused at daycare and
like by nannies and like that sort of
thing like you're opening your child up
that could still happen even if I'm not
working it's a lot less likely if you
are not necessarily because if the
person let's say the person
um doing the abusing was a family member
you know like you hear you know
unquestion stuff like that I know I've
I've only got to take my child to see
their Uncle once a week for that to
happen it doesn't matter whether I'm
working or not that stuff can still
happen I I know but you wouldn't say
like it would be less likely if you were
there see 65 hours remember
I'm saying I would cut it down okay
let's let's cut it down to 40. yeah
that's still full that's still full time
yeah yeah
but I don't think the child's going to
be on the ends with the gangs
the possibility of abuse is any larger
just because I am at work so and I have
a question so you put yourself in do you
want to be married
yeah so you put yourself in the guy's
point of view what what does he get from
a wife that's working all the time if
he's making money your money's nothing
to him
so what would he and he doesn't get a
mother why would he marry you
we are building a life together though
I'd still like to think that I would be
a mother because I'm also trying to
provide for our children making sure we
have better things together so like for
example if what I'm saying you can't you
can't say anything with your career and
your money because if a guy if a guy has
money so all of my brothers they make
six figures all of them and they don't
give a [ __ ] about a girl's money like
it's nothing to them because they have
money
so you can't say money anything else
because most guys then they get married
they want a mother for their children
but if you're not going to be the mother
what do they get I'd still be a mother I
don't think me working stops me being a
mother like
no way it absolutely does no my sister
and her boyfriend they've got one child
together they both still work she
doesn't work like a full-time or finish
his work at like three or what not she's
still a mother to her child does it does
her does the part does her partner make
six figures no if he made six figures do
you think she would pay for a thing
pay for a child care do you pay do you
think she'd be paying for anything if
her partner was making six figures
no the answer is no and you can't this
is actually uh the more um so I'm
opening a wife's school soon so if you
ever if you if you're a three or four
and you want to be a wife sign up for my
school
yeah
not not me I'm not a wife but I've been
talking to like women like I've talked
to this woman who fostered 10 children
um and like she's like a homemaker and
um
she said she raised 10 kids on less than
10 000 a year and like but most people
refuse to move out of the city because
they want the lifestyle
so I mean like a lot of [ __ ] like she
was saying that a lot of people like
think you need two incomes but they just
like want to eat out they want new
clothes they want like like imagine it's
about the lifestyle yeah but with the
Joneses but I think naturally with that
lifestyle comes slightly better things
and opportunities as well if you look at
a child whose um parents are potentially
living in poverty against a child whose
parents are making a bit of money
they've got better things for school
um better opportunities when they're
older you know maybe their parents can
buy their first car and so on whereas
the other child hasn't got that straight
away well there's one thing you can't
buy it which is which is time which is
time and teaching so the T So for that
child I think uh my I would want to
teach that child and if it's not
necessarily me doing it full time
because I might be at work I would want
someone who I am but what if what if I'm
working whilst a child's at school I
pick the child up from school I can't be
be a mother to him at school that's
different that's after that I mean yeah
I think that's most people would be fine
with that but when they're under the age
of five and even if it's after school
that's I don't think that's 40 hours a
week because what is it they get to
school at nine they stop at what 2 30.
yeah you'll be working part-time at that
point really
it's part time I definitely just
wouldn't give up a career
I want to ask sorry quickly what is a
definition of a career
what jobs are we actually talking about
here when you say career
it's real that's a good question well as
in what jobs do I see as a career yeah
like if you say career what would you
what what kind of what profession
um
depends I guess it depends really it
could be on many professions I.E like
um a lady could be a hairdresser but see
that as a career because she's doing
really well in it I think it depends you
can't say that just because they're
working at so and so that's not a career
I mean I I can you think cutting hair is
more important than being a mother
I can I can absolutely that say that
kind of care is not more important than
being a mom and raising your kids and
being there
you never know you've used my chains
once you have a kid ah listen when
you're a kid you're going to be a
full-time you have a kid you become a
full-time hairdresser automatically
automatically so it's like there's
nothing greater than you can gift the
world than life itself
there's nothing better than that as a
woman that's why you get blessed to be a
woman we as men started off as women in
the theaters and deformed into what we
are now everything starts as a female
everything that's more expensive in the
world as a female why because it can
create it can procreate and if you take
away your right the value of your
creation you take away the value of your
eggs you take away the value of your
ovaries you lost the feminism because
feminism all they are is a bunch of
women who want to be the F boys that
they say they hate they want to sleep if
you're ready you want to sleep with they
want to work out all the jobs that men
are working at
they want to walk around with no clothes
on no shirts and [ __ ] on they want to
become the men that they say they hate
and in the mix of it they finesse women
out of all of your benefits
what about you would you give up your
career for kids yeah yeah I would why
um because I think having choosing to
have a kid is is selfish anyway it's so
like it's a decision that you've chosen
to make to bring a child into the world
so you're responsible for that child
you're responsible for nurturing that
child and being there and
if
you don't think if it's done right it's
the most selfless thing you can do I
mean in terms of like for the the child
doesn't have a choice
in coming into world you make that
decision right okay so it's selfish okay
I mean you make message so if you're not
in a position to have a child or you
want to work 70 hours a week that's not
fair on the child you're not there for
them they they're not they're not being
nurtured or cared for in the way that
they need
um so yeah I would if I chose to have a
kid and the only way to
be there for my kid is to give up my job
because after they've gone to school I
can build my career back up
so it's not like I can once I've left I
can never go back and that's it I can
build my career back up or find a way to
work around my children would you give
up lifestyle for kids
for a family
yeah okay
yeah I would so like no no eating out no
I don't care about those things no new
clothes no nothing yeah I mean I would
too yeah yeah I'm quite a simple person
at the core of it so yeah
um as many of you know I was just banned
on Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible